my name is police ela Brock and since I  can remember I've wanted to dance  Oh No here we go it was there with my  mom when I was a baby  bene see I know you have this trade  dreams are not reality dance school in  Paris dancer at the ballet you wouldn't  have more than five minutes  Paris city of dreams dance yes training  starts at 5 a.m.  can we push to after lunch are you do  you have the energy of a bullet you also  have the lightness of a depressed  elephant yeah what if she's good mother  got that part  do you hear me reality check little rats  you can work as hard as you like you can  drink 24 hours a day but you will always  be nothing you have something she can  only dream of  passion  right here right now  [Music]  [Music]  no matter what happens never give up on  your dreams  you  [Music]  I like you Khaleesi are you chewing gum  I'm stretching  [Music]